you know what I was thinking earlier
imagine aliens came to our planet and
landed in America and they said take me
to your leader this is what would they
think
they blow us out yeah they just be like
this isn't worth it like just gone
um there's a story that just came out
maybe that's why they're not visiting
yeah I mean that's I mean these are ants
they show up like it's us looking at it
yeah
like who's calling the shots here this
guy no no no no no I don't know I think
if they did show up they would treat us
the way we treat like animals you know
we'd sit back and watch and then be and
you know it's like it's funny because
you ever watch Meerkat Manor no I
haven't seen it's like all the meerkats
they go to war with like the meerkats
have war and tribes and stuff and you
know they talk about the leader and they
give them silly names that's what the
aliens are probably doing they're like
the Biden family is ridiculed by many
well I don't know if the islands have
British accents or anything